i mean we'll we'll talk about
psychedelics and treating
in uh bringing some of trauma to the
surface and dealing with all those kinds
of things but
there's something also to the opening up
of creativity
for whether it's for writing purposes or
for
for in my world for engineering or
invention
innovation and invention itself is a
very it's a deeply creative process
and it's fascinating to think
with the aid of psychedelics what kind
of ideas can be brought to life
yeah well we have the whole phenomena of
a lot of the people in silicon valley
and else micro dosing psychedelics in
order to
have a little touch more of this
creative approach to things
i would love it to see if it was that's
more like terence mckenna territory
correct me if i'm wrong but i would love
to serve more scientific to where
there will be the rigor of saying how to
do it effectively
you know how to sort of understand sort
of um
not just almost um
you know to take the full
journey of creative exploration and to
do it for
prolonged periods of time you know um
for years you know life-long kind of
part of your life
of hot it empowers creativity i think
of course you start with um
helping people uh deal with trauma
and then the next step is people who
have moved past their trauma and are
trying to do something
create something special in their life
how can then psychedelics empower that
yeah now that also just to not shy away
from anything controversial yes
um that has to that gets us to this um
idea of psychedelics for vision quest
particularly for younger people you know
when you're
sort of moving into this adulting kind
of phase and you have to figure out what
are you going to do with your life
there's so many options a lot of people
of course feel constrained that they
have very few options but
i think this idea of psychedelics as a
way to help you
find your calling or find your vision or
find your unique leverage point
i think we'll see that more and more as
our culture evolves and gets healthier
around the use of psychedelics it says
both the science
uh having the rigor of understanding how
to do it safely and the culture catching
up
to the fact that this is uh both safe
and uh like very useful
yeah although i would question this idea
of safety
so so we can understand physiological
risks
and we can minimize them and i think
there's very minimal
physiological risks from the classic
psychedelics virtually none
or for even mdma under safe conditions
psychological risks are
harder to address but we can do that
through the sense of safety and support
but i think there's um a level of risk
there that we shouldn't um overlook
and so you know to make a drug into a
medicine what we have to do is prove to
the satisfaction of
the fda and other regulatory agencies
that things are safe and efficacious
but even though they use those words
proving safety and
safe and efficacious it's in
relationship to the disease that you're
trying to treat and you accept a certain
amount of risk
so it's the risk benefit ratio rather
than
pure safety yeah absolutely
you